protests in Haiti this time around led
by men in police uniforms they were
angry about the killings of officers
over the last few days
they killed 15 policemen in one month
after guard then comes the police we
stand with our policemen
some went to the capitals airport
stopping prime minister Ariel Henry from
leaving it after he arrived from a
summit in Argentina
we need a revolution we need to have a
bloodbath if Ariel Henry signs are pact
with the bandits a lot of police are
dead and he didn't say anything not even
a tweet for the policeman who died we
are in the streets to fight for our
brothers and sisters who are victimized
by the bandits we have to take to the
streets every day to get what we want
eventually prime minister Henry managed
to leave the airport but he's at the
head of a political crisis in Haiti
[Music]
powerful gangs now control more than 60
percent of the capital Puerto Prince
following a breakdown in institutional
order triggered by the assassination of
President jovenel Moyes in 2021
unleashing levels of violence not seen
here in decades
extorting murdering raping to control
those in their dominions gangs have
increasingly resorted to the deliberate
killing of men women and children
as young as 10 years old
have been brutally raped a tactic that
spread fear
and destroys the social fabric of
communities under the control of rival
gangs the Haitian police are hopelessly
overmatched the United Nations is
advocating for an international force to
be deployed to keep Law and Order in the
country but so far no one wants to lead
it
meanwhile Haiti Burns slipping ever
closer to a failed State John Holman Al
Jazeera